Welcome back everyone this is going to be
my new Loki deleted scenes video, alternate
ending for the finale.
There were whole bunch of scenes in alternate
storylines that the director in the producers
the writers talked about after the finale
was released.
So we'll break it all down.
There's a bunch of really cool Easter eggs
and stuff though probably try to do during
season two that they just deleted from season
one is a set in previous videos what just
happened on Loki will also influence what's
happening on marvel's what if series, which
is a big multiverse series big multiverse
first the avengers team will be doing full
episode videos for that it will start in a
couple weeks on Disney plus so be sure to
subscribe to get all those videos.
Thankfully we won't have to wait too long
to see the consequences of which is happen
but careful for spoilers for everything that
happened on Loki if you have not watched the finale yet
Because we talk about everything will start
with the alternate ending first and I'll talk
about some of the other deleted scenes from
earlier in the finale episode in that some
of the other episodes to we've learned about
some extra deleted scenes and connections
to what was happening during the alternate
storylines in the finale is based on some
of this stuff they made some huge changes
I think for the better for the finale.
Like originally the finale was very different.
But probably the biggest change to the alternate
ending of the finale is that Kang was originally
only going to be a big post credit scene for
those you that wondered why there was in a
bigger post credit scene we said that really
short scene to the season two announcement
it was kind of more of a mid credit scene
in a post credit scene.
But that was in effect sort of the replacement
to the post credit scene.
That would've been there big Kang reveal moment.
But in that original version of the finale.
There was a going to be any of the Kang stuff
during the actual episode, it would completely
change three quarters of the episode itself.
Because after about the first 10 minutes in
the finale as we saw it is all Kang explaining
everything to Loki and Sylvie he's in most
of the episode in the report is that originally
instead of Kang showing up within the first
few minutes of the episode.
We would've gotten of vastly longer miss minutes
temptation scene where she list off all these
different things that Kang is willing to give
them changes in their timeline in order to
get them to turn around and go home.
So to speak like leave the citadel at the
end of time.
But remember, that was all part of the big
Willy Wonka style test him testing them to
see if they were worthy to make a Thor movies
reference.
Let he who is worthy take the place of Kang
inside his citadel at the end of time in Italy
structurally the citadel itself would have
been the same this version of chronopolis
that they're doing from Kang storyline from
the immortus storyline really because he's
more like immortus in this instance than he
is like Kang is calling him Kang because it's
a little bit easier.
So it's kind of taken name and go with it.
Although technically he's more like Nathaniel
Richards prime the idea is that at the early
part of the episode.
They would spend a lot more time on Loki struggled
to say no to Kang's initial offer this temptation
the last temptation of Christ.
The key here though when directly talking
to Miss minutes is when the Thor Ragnarok
theme music starts playing in the background
while miss minutes is listing off all the
things that he can have an in theory, because
we don't actually see in the final version
of the episode while this is happening he's
thinking to himself first second the theoretically
he could use the infinity gauntlet to save
Asgard from Ragnarok that's why that Ragnarok
theme music is playing save his people from
being destroyed by thanos save his mother
from dying so would've been nobler reason
to want to say yes to Kang's offer.
Like okay I will take the deal.
I will turn around and go if you give me all
the stuff but the ideas that we would see
more of that internal struggle that Loki was
having just play out on screen so that's basically
where the king Loki scene came from.
It was part of the last temptation of Christ
sequence during the early part of the episode,
but also in this version of the episode where
there was no Kang during the episode have
all this extra time because he spends the
entire episode explained to them.
They would also replaced a lot of those Kang
scenes with Loki and Sylvie trying to convince
each other what the right course of action
would be.
Whereas in the final version of the episode.
Their fight is very brief right at the end.
Like if they didn't actually have their little
battle right at the end they would been no
fighting at all during the finale it would've
been all talking.
Although to think about him actually not that
mad about it.
Just because I was so happy with what they
did with the Kang character normally get kind
of upset of there's an episode without any
kind of action, especially if it's the finale.
So everything that you hear Kang say during
the finale.
Like all the scenes we got in the actual version
the finale everything he does in the episode
sounds like it was stuff that they added during
the force shut down that they had because
of the virus last year.
Whereas a lot of the other series.
Like falcon and winter soldier and Wandavision
the exact opposite happen.
There was a huge movie character.
Like Doctor strange that originally was part
of their plans for Wandavision kind of baked
into the way they wrote the episodes and a
lot of the teasers.
But while the virus shut down was happening.
They just decided to completely remove him
from the episode rest of his the Loki people
did the reverse like you know what working
to put the big movie character whose gonna
be our next thanos level villain in the episode now
But the way the writers explained Kang in
their talks with Kevin Feige developing the
series before they ever started filming Kang
was always meant to be the person behind everything
from day one when Kevin Feige first started
meeting with them about writing the episodes
this is it was always a thing that Marvel
wanted from the very start, which is a question
of how they were going to revealed that it
was Kang the whole time, it sounds like they
just love Jonathan majors performance so much
in his screen test when he was auditioning
for Kang that they decided to double down
on him.
And I'm so happy that they did he was the
MVP of the episode.
He said to be amazing is all these other alternate
infinite versions of Kang that will pop up
all over the MCU and think a lot of the way
the end of this change because they decided
to do a season 2
early on in production.
So they knew they were gonna have a season 2.
Whereas they didn't have that during Wandavision
and falcon and winter soldier so they were
able to have a little bit more fun to sort
of being propulsive teasing future marvel movies
But also teasing a lot of what's gonna be
happening during Loki season two.
Just in terms of Kang's whole speech setting
him up as the next thanos level villain infinite
versions of him free from their own timelines
all coming for war, each with their own agendas
do not be surprised if pockets of them ban
together briefly sometimes Kang versions will
work together across different points in their
timeline but usually they find themselves
at odds with each other to hilarious consequences
is just as good a chance that the Kings will
all wind up killing each other before the
new Avengers in the fantastic four will have
a chance to defeat them.
But I do have a big Kang explainer video for
the future of his character in the MCU what's
happening with him next that will post tomorrow.
I was waiting a couple days because are so
many spoiler he things we have to talk about
in their still probably a couple people that
have not watched the finale yet.
The director also revealed that in this early
scene here after this whole 10 Tatian scene
went south after Loki and Sylvie denied her
there was going to be big fight scene with
miss minutes herself way she talks about she
says that she wanted their to feel like something
more sinister about miss minutes in the way
they presented her in the episode sort of
took her from that comedic old time he cartoon
feeling to flat out whore but he just pops
up in front of them.
Hey y'all only people freaked out at that
jump scared that they used her for the beginning
of the episode.
Some of the other writers talked about what
was happening during this big miss minutes
fight scene the idea was though they were
going to pay off the moment from the beginning
of episode to where she was testing Loki while
standing outside the monitor.
Like in 3D space he started to swat her as
a joke asking her if she was a recording or
if she was alive and she just responds sorta
miss minutes is kind of like the boss level
future tech upgrade to vision and Ultron and
she's not invincible.
It just that they don't have the understanding
of how her programming works or how she exists
the technology that Kang used to create her
is so advanced from the vastly different future
the MCU that no one seen it yet.
The other part of the big fight scene with
miss minutes would have been them walking
through the halls before they meet Kang where
they would've had to fight all of the greatest
warriors from across the timeline bring back.
Not just the ones that are gone are dead but
also MCU characters from the future that we
have not seen yet.
Mostly the big familiar a list characters
though if you remember Mysterio solutions
when he was fighting Spider-Man during Spider-Man
no way home.
Like he made him see all these visions of
dead avengers.
Like the zombie version of Iron Man you think
about Kang's 3D PowerPoint presentation technology
where he manifested these 3D models will he
was explaining his backstory in the history
of the MCU the multiversal war you have to
imagine miss minutes forming avengers characters
using the same type of technology.
It was also going to be a longer deleted scene
of them walking through what they called Kang's
display room which would've been on the lower
levels and it would've been like a larger
version of Renslayer's trophy case with Kang
collecting artifacts and across history and
it would've been full of Easter eggs from
the marvel movies so far and from future marvel
movies that we haven't seen yet.
Like characters in the future.
Like the fantastic four galactus silver surfer
Easter eggs X-Men mutants Eternals characters
celestials artifacts and Easter eggs the writers
also reveal there were a bunch of deleted
scenes from Mobius and Renslayer's ending
scene together.
But it was cut short because the virus last
year.
This is those scenes would've explored more
of their relationship when Mobius was trying
to throw it in their face and they were going
back and forth on who was betraying who the
thousands of years that they spent being friends
working together the TVA.
There were also a lot of deleted scenes with
Renslayer flashbacks to when she was just
this badass judge wrecking everyone in sight
during her missions in the idea was as that's
why she was promoted to judge eventually became
so powerful within the TVA and why Kang took
so much of an interest in her, particularly
in the ideas the because Kang was the real time keepers.
This whole time because they were just fake
proxies for him to used issue commands through
Kang himself was the one who guided Renslayer
on her path for thousands of years to become
this very powerful figure inside the TVA on
her own journey so to speak like he paved
the road for her the way he said he paved
the road for Loki and Sylvie, but they said
that because they did have a lot of time to
cover her history the TVA her history with
Kang, even though she didn't know was Kang
this whole time.
The probably to start covering some of that,
during Loki season two logo boom bottom raw
made it sound like she might also cameo in
some of the upcoming marvel movies is her.
Like a sub boss alongside versions of Kang
it could be alternate versions of her character as well
Just like we see, alternate versions of Kang
it wasn't clear pretty much all of the Loki
characters are coming back for Loki season
two.
Including Sylvie just answering what happened
to Sylvie after she killed Kang she would've
taken her tempad that she used to send Loki
back to the citadel and she would is gone
back to one of her safe houses in one of the
other apocalypses which is like Loki goes
back to find this very different change timeline
version of the TVA.
So the would've also probably encountered
similar changes to wherever she goes back
to but after this shall be dealing with the
consequences of her actions regrets about
killing him in eventually on her own hero
arc.
Just like Loki got during season one.
So eventually they will be reunited during
Loki season 2 at some point I've already done
another video with the other deleted scenes
from earlier in the episode.
Like, there's a deleted scene with frog Thor
versus Loki Throg versus Loki let a link for
that video down in the description.
But there are a lot of deleted scenes from
across the entire series most of the other
ones I do cover in that throng video if they
reveal any more really big mind blowing deleted
scenes from the finale or other parts of the
series are alternate storylines.
I will do a new video about it.
But I think this covers most of it.
Like I said probably the most mind blowing
change is that they actually added all the
Kang stuff in at the last minute and I am
so happy that they did that, everyone post
all your reactions to these deleted scenes
the alternate ending in.
Like I said I have a big Kang video that will
post this weekend so make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss that.
Congratulations Domblue your the giveaway
winner from my last big marvel video.
Please email me on the about page my channel
so I can get your contact details everyone
click here for my full Loki episode 6 finale
video and click here for my Loki ending
and credit scene video.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys tonight!